above all else President Trump was
elected on one clear issue stop illegal
immigration and that would mean build
the wall no amnesty you know the drill
but there are some Republicans in
Congress including the guy right here
who still believes that the daca amnesty
thing is a winning idea and one of them
of course is here to defend that and
that's Scott Taylor from the second
District of Virginia congressman it's
great to see you Mitchell oh that's good
great great to have you here now you
wrote a letter to Paul Ryan's 34 your
fellow congressmen signed it and in this
letter you say it's an important agenda
item now to give these 800,000 people
brought here as young people amnesty why
is that of all the things that we have
to deal with in our country why are you
so obsessed with catering to the needs
of illegal immigrants well thank you for
having me of course congratulations your
show you use two words that I completely
take issue with number one is amnesty
right but let me preface this by saying
that was with the White House a couple
days ago and my position is basically my
personal position now I can't speak for
everybody it's on the letter because
there's different opinions and stuff
like that and where they want to be with
this but for me personally I'm with the
president I think what President Obama
did was illegal I think it's under
congressional purview when him pushing
it down there I agree with that 100% I'm
with you no I supported more money
already more money than over a decade
for homeland 1.5 billion dollars in
appropriations for the wall I don't care
about that but for that I mean I Kate's
law all those things I think we should
get more security I think we should get
your verify I think we should have a a
program of course for are you against
chain migration yes so you for the raise
act yeah I actually am I think we should
okay but I'm trying to understand why I
know you know let me pushing I'm not
obsessed okay so that's what I'm saying
let let me finish I'm saying I'm for all
those things I think we should move
towards I think we should have a program
for unaccompanied minors to get them
back safely over back to their parents
that should be in conjunction with
dealing with this population amnesty by
definition as you very well know is
basically given forgiveness for people
who have offended this country much of
me in that position know but Scott
there's read
the president asked is against you why
Ally Pally packet Ally pack is the
organization that is for legal
immigration they put you on the top of
their list as the Republican that is
most pushing the amnesty for the daca
recipients without real strings attached
yeah you throw that's complete crap yeah
that is complete limit let me know you
throw more money no no no no that is
complete crap I'm not for the DREAM Act
I'm not for that I am for a standalone
thing that gets more security and more
disincentives for illegal immigration in
conjunction with dealing with this
population let me say something you have
these groups out there who are pushing
that who raise money who have hundreds
of thousands of dollars in salaries for
their people like numbers USA and these
other other core organizations that
raise money off Republican donors to
attack other Republicans I'm not for
that I'm not for that position in fact
like I said I was with the White House
and you're gonna hear you called
president Trump's rhetoric divisive and
you blamed him in part for blowing the
Virginia race did you not on CNN I just
watch the clip like five minutes I will
absolutely say to you as I did before
Virginia is a freakin Virginian now is a
blue state I know it is I know it I
don't agree well really Northern
Virginia expands me ever meant
demographic changes answer your
questions that you want to keep stepping
on me I do not think that Virginia is a
is a perpetual blue state I think it is
there I think if we're gonna say that
bobble bob mcdonnell's election in 2009
was a referendum on Obama's policy which
I agree
we have to be intellectually honest and
certainly the national scene contributes
to the rise and Democrat turnout all
across that's my Gillespie was a New
Jersey guy who was a bush IT tried to do
the latter-day populism it didn't work
he ran before it didn't work he can't be
trouble he's not Trump there's no
question you you still think President
Trump his devices I think he can't be
device sure I think the polls show that
I support the president the wall I
support the president and I support more
money for the wall you've been saying
that you support the president many many
segments however his positions like mine
on immigration it's the same American
people before the illegal immigrants and
you'll win your next problem
pro-american I'm an American dreamer hey
stay with us we're all dreamers first